sonnerat banque justement par les
libérations qui vous a consacré un
portrait lundi dernier un portrait titre
et directrice de la rédaction dans
lequel il y des réactionnaires action
exactement aussi électrique de la
réaction dans lequel il évoque vos deux
postes à ces nouveaux europe 1 vos
audiences qui ne cesse de progresser
votre notoriété qui est en train
d'exploser sauf que certains termes
utilisés par le journaliste ou choquer
des lecteurs dont géraldine maillet
certes internes ont été eux voilà vu
comme impartiaux voir sexistes brushing
à la fox news au vent la présentatrice
franco-tunisienne appel à l'insoumission
contre les fatwas culturel la révolution
racialiste et la décadence
alors ce jeu vous donne quelques
quelques passages rien de pierre lourde
de maquillage et de somaliens à l'heure
de la sieste
après une matinée en direct et une nuits
sur netflix lakhouad la quadra voilà
redouble d'amabilités jean pierre
elkabbach a repéré cette fille de la
bourgeoisie tunisienne en lisant jeune
afrique à la fin des années 2000 et
cette femme de houellebecq musulmane
laïcarde mais spirituelle attaché à
l'idée de destins considère que les
catholiques français devraient se
désinhiber beaucoup beaucoup de
réactions et bien votre ami michel
onfray philosophe qu'on a appelés pour
ce portrait qu'a dit selon lui le but
était de vous faire mal
voilà il me l'a dit libé me propose de
la tuer belle conception du journalisme
sonia mabrouk fait partie des rares
journalistes qui respecte car elle fait
un travail remarquable et courageuse
contre-courant des facilités qui
permettent de faire carrière à ce que ça
vous à ça vous a blessé ce nom parce que
je voudrais pas me victimise et ce
serait trop facile et le discours est
tellement porté ici sur ce plateau que
je ne ferai pas parce que ce n'est pas
ma nature et j'ai joué le jeu parce que
quand libération mama m'a proposé ce
portrait je me suis dit au contraire
c'est l'occasion de pouvoir avoir un
débat j'ai consécration que ce soit bon
ou mauvais un nom mais très bien vous
verrez le probablement dans un aspect
médiatique mais sur le débat d idées moi
c'est ça qui m'intéresse est pouvoir
enfin avoir quelqu'un qui est vraiment
contre de manière substantielle vraiment
les idées de pouvoir avoir cet avis-là
et malheureusement pas ce que je
reproche à ce portrait si je pouvais
reproché au delà de ce que vous avez dit
c'est surtout qu'on est pas aller au
fond des sujets c'est qu'on a consacré
du temps à parler des idées et que
finalement il n'y a pas ce débat là
cette bataille qui est une émulation et
qui ressort bon bah écoutez est-ce que
vous avez cités toussaint prochain
la fox nous ouvrons c'est la
présentatrice tron côtes tunisiennes ça
vous demande ce sont des coûts vous
savez dans le débat public et on l'a ici
on peut ne pas être d'accord on a des
visions je pense qu'on a des convictions
faysal puissants pendant ce temps j'ai
dit une certaine idée de la france
moi je les ai vécus ainsi deux côtés de
la méditerranée les sublimer la france
c'est pour ça que quand on dit on se bat
contre les discriminations moi je pense
très sincèrement on ne peut le faire
qu'en semble mêmes tous sens je vais
terminer tous ensemble c'est ça veut
dire c'est une vraie conviction quand je
dis pour la france il ya ces trans
partisan c'est pour ça que j'aurais
préféré qu'il est ce débat là plutôt que
des mimes sous la ceinture parce qu'à la
fin de l'interview c'est ce qui m'a le
plus frappé alors gérald images avaient
été choqués par foyer - sonia vous êtes
très digne comme d'habitude mais moi
excusez moi j'ai trouvé cet article
absolument répugnant hrb dégueulasse
libé ne se vend plus donc ils cherchent
le buzz ça c'est normal et je trouve
qu'il est sexiste
il est raciste socialement il est
raciste ou qu'on en fait vous êtes la
mauvaise arabe ne leur plaît pas moi je
pense que dont moi ça m'a choqué j'ai
trouvé ça absolument dégueulasse
alors j'ai eu eux aussi ils s'attaquent
à la femme c'est ça qui m'a gêné
profondément c'est qu'ils s'attaquent
pas la journaliste et sur le plan des
idées on peut vous combattre mais là il
s'attaque à la femme il avait très
clairement moi je les connais libe il
voulait se payer sonia mabrouk volailles
sont allés directement et je pense que
vous êtes tombé dans le piège et au
début vous leur ouvrait la porte
allez-y bousculer mois il se sent des
boum on y va ça a été une politique
rédactionnelle et moi je suis gêné parce
qu'on n'attaque pas une femme parce que
c'est une femme c'est absurde c'est un
non sens journalistique mais en réalité
j'ai serré le pardonnez moi quand on
vient voir moi ou d'autres c'est en
s'attend à un discours tout simplement
on s'attend à ce qu'on dit c'est écoutez
on n'est pas fiers d'être français ou
français sont là on s'attend à ce qu'on
les écoute et j'ai vécu toute ma vie des
discriminations on s'attend à ce qu'on
dise écouter à cause de ma religion de
gens vivent en groupe c'est ma religion
dig s attend à voir ce discours-là est
aujourd'hui de plus en plus moi et
d'autres rachel kahn ex tara il y a un
discours qui est construit et qui est
sincère de dire non mais vous et non
seulement il ya une histoire
monde ce pays comme j'aime la tunisie
d'air ce débat mais ça m'a toujours
frappé notre tunisie natale c'est qu'on
peut la voir très simplement et
sincèrement tunisie et on peut pas la
voir en france et moi je ne veux pas
laisser cela pris en otage par des
individus des gens dont vous avez ça on
ne laissera pas être des plus puissants
valente déjà allez-vous vous arrivez le
peuple tunisien alors que vous même vous
défendiez ben ali donc un moment donné
faut arrêter cinq secondes plus tard il
est où le problème à damas broussy
d'éprouver un thème d'année mais mary
communes adhérentes en empêche pas de
sel à vous approprier la tunisie
conserve les arrangements d'accord et
alors ce que tu disais rien n'est pas
d'accord
merci le problème à damas brooks et que
vous comprenez pas que ya un monopole en
fait de sept disques de ce discours
réactionnaire vous l'avez sur europe 1
vous l'avez sûr c'est nous et vous dites
pas un moment donné on est toujours dans
l'antre soit on discute avec une
minorité à poignée de gens c'est pas
anodin que dans le cevipof par exemple
qui est un des des enquêtes les plus
importantes montre que l'institution la
plus détestée parmi les plus détestés de
ddd français et sont les femmes arrêtent
et mas qu'ils ont enfin en fait des
demandes ils ont marre en fait c'était
par la ministre je ne peux pas du tout
fan oui on défend des thèses
universaliste on défend une servira
aussi à mairieux devions monsieur mourir
les majorettes français ça veut dire ne
rien dire de l'air circule